si la mission de la reine elizabeth ii
aujourd'hui elle fait ses 95 ans
quelques jours seulement après le décès
de son mari le prince philip
une célébration en tout petit comité
centre adi sionnel coup de canon
portrait entouré de ses petits-enfants
ou arrière petits enfants
rien n'est encore fixé pour la parade
militaire appelée trooping the colour
qui célèbrent officiellement mi juin
l'anniversaire des monarques
britanniques
la fameuse parade militaire avait déjà
été réduite l'an dernier pour cause de
crise sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre nouvelle idole bertrand des kern
spécialiste de la mort ah oui bien
entendu derrière caen deckers écrivain
journaliste comme en voit la reine la
reine elle va fêter jal a fêté son anniv
bon c'était pas la folie la pauvre ce
match avait ramené de bougies oui eh
bien écoutez bravo le voit qu'on a un
petit budget et ses 95 ans ce matin au
château de windsor
oui alors il paraît que c'est le gâteau
qu'a eue la reine ben c'est une copie je
sais bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il croyait vraiment je croyais que
c'était le vrai gâteau qui a eu l'arrêt
j'aurais pu donner à windsor pour fou
alors c'est le gâteau qu'elle a eue
c'est la réplique du gâteau elle a eu
que savamment scato cette conférence
non il était probablement plus grand
mais c'est en chocolat 3 yal que c'est
vraiment la recette officielle il
désactive et c'est le chocolat quoi
royal cake fait un gâteau au chocolat
avec des biscuits des biscuits
croustillant viennent de chez fortinet
sense qui sont un vieux fournisseur
breveté torturé fortunés mais sonne vrai
voilà fortunés mais sonne à l'égard de
biscuits dans ce jeu là la bar-mitsva de
son fils à faire quoi et donc essayé
d'aimer je suis très fier bah oui c'est
quand même de muscu sont pas donné mais
ils ont la particularité d'être très
croustillant et d'être les favoris
d'elizabeth ii elle encore des goûts
[Musique]
woods est conscient il a perdu son gala
a fait perdre et danser en bas et où
comme ça alors mais c'est bon quoi oui
alors qu'eric la raf simons en à deux
doigts d'être en guerre avec la gaule et
royaume uni
oui alors et donc elle a mangé c'est la
bouffe et ce alors on essaiera de
windsor ce n'est pas parce que avec le
corps et naba ne pouvait pas fait cela à
l'intérieur donc ça s'est fait à
l'extérieur
ah oui j'allais sur leur droite donc
qu'ils ont sorti il m'a mis là ils ont
dit tu vas manger ton bien à l'extérieur
voilà c'est chouette avec un très beau
service à thé en porcelaine qui est trop
c'est vrai et qui a été créée tout
spécialement pour les 95 cents en quoi
ils ont les hôtes à limoges non non ils
ont aussi des manufactures de porcelaine
d'abord et leur quoi bertrand donc fort
réduit non parce que j'adorerais que
j'adore quand on était à l'anniversaire
de la reine
ouais mais ça vient ils ont fait un truc
de porcelaine pour elle pour ses 95 ans
teaser son cadeau ça lui amène son
cadeau c'est monsieur cadeaux la
porcelaine
ah non elle n'est qu'à nord ben ça
dépend tout le monde peut apporter son
cadeau on a eu des gars du coin comme
cadeau alors braff ça il faut vraiment
être fort travaille aussi dans le var ce
qu'elle et lui comme cadeau par contre
je peux vous dire c'est qu'elle
affectionne particulièrement
songa son cadeau favori c'est les carrés
hermès
non on utilise encore pour monter à
cheval ah ouais poney japonais non
seulement elle monte à cheval ou encore
line et l'incroyable ces ours mais moi
je monte à cheval très belle mon cachot
accéder au carré hermès autour du cou
elodie recommencer l'europe ça malgré un
point commun avec avec la reine parce
que j'ai le mien mon carré hermès vous
pouvez le mettre autour du poignet
autour des cheveux autour du cou sur le
sac ça se met d'accord merci voilà
bifurqué sur la modèle merci ça tiens
voilà déjà reparti harry sans attendre
son anniversaire la partie m'arrêter en
effet même si éric alors à sa très bonne
question d'isabelle puisque harry ne
peux pas t'en de l'anniversaire de la
reine oui c'est vrai qu'il aurait dû
attend ça c'est pas beau ça
dans un message envoyé vais quand même
assez fort mais en même temps néanmoins
je ne protège pas boissarie loi de la
méta chez quand même que le prince
william n'était pas là non plus il est
retourné à londres il à kensington dans
son palais à londres et le prince
charles il n'était pas non plus il est
au pays de galles futur edouard savez
celui qui est suspecté de la famille
stein verts et de philippe oui j'avais
loire en la vertu d'accords et edwards
alors quand il s'est tu crois
l'anniversaire ben non il y avait les
belles filles aussi et apparemment le
génie et béatrice ont fait une
apparition
c'est qui ceux là se sont elles mêmes si
tu fumes ada qui sont tous les fils d'or
et ses défis de y'a quoi exactement
passé ça oui mais est-ce que c'est vrai
que kate faisaient des animations vidéo
pour pas la laisser tout seul à lui
parler par vidéo et lui faisait
rencontrer des gens à distance
apparemment il ya lui en jambes de
tourine est tournée royale en quelque
sorte où ils essayent chacun de se
relayer en sorte pour ne pas la laisser
vraiment tout seul
et là et cette idée à la dernière minute
d'organiser quelque chose dans les
jardins pour que justement il puisse
être plusieurs
et alors on dit il ya aurait de quelques
photos puissent par la presse à part a
dit à l'ats promenait ses chiens il lui
reste 2 courgettes jamais adoptée à leur
ai fait une promenade avec les chiens
dont on est dans les chiffres
elle l'a fait construire c'était le soir
ou le matin normalement
traditionnellement il ya là là
piketty ressentent sans trois coups de
canon à dallas et même à mike quoi il ya
des gars quand même six protocoles comme
l'a fait et sans rester pas
l'anniversaire de ses si elle est née le
21 avril on peut peut-être dire aussi
que l'anniversaire chaque année c'était
au mois de juin à ce qu il fait meilleur
non sport avec moi et le deuxième samedi
du mois de juin donc en fait et son
anniversaire sandrine bailly la vraie
fête ce sera au mois de juin voilà donc
aujourd'hui elle ne fait en tout petit
comité
d'accord et en juin je vois le gâteau je
retire mon c est donc un bon coup elle a
soufflé les bougies et où ils ont coupé
le gâteau est apparemment la sauvetat de
bauchi son gâteau préféré ça la reine
ces monuments
et pour la petite anecdote vers nador
tellement le gâteau au chocolat mois que
mark flanagan qui gère les cuisines
royales raconté cet axe est petite
histoire il dit lorsqu'il reste un
morceau de gâteau au chocolat
l à fait imaginer une boîte métallique
pour pouvoir transporter le gâteau de
résidence en résidence lorsqu'elle
lorsqu'elle bourges
non non ils peuvent parfaire un gâteau
sourire à la fin de la prière les débats
ils sont blindés
c'est justement ça me fout et justement
c'est pas possible c'est vrai et kate
winslet oui j'ai un copain il regarde un
film et kate winslet qu'attali moi kate
middleton
et elle elle fait tout pour faire bien
voir aller déjà parfaite way avait
vraiment elle est là bas en angleterre
pour y aller oui beaucoup puisque mégane
et on a des nouvelles de son état quand
même parce qu'elle vient de perdre son
mari comment elle était aujourd'hui
parce que ça nous mettra aujourd'hui on
sait la réserve et non apparemment si
elle est en bonne forme c'est peut-être
un peu beaucoup mais si elle est la
clape l'on dise on est alors il ya cette
anecdote city racontée par la presse qui
est assez drôle
elle dit qu'elle est envahie noyé par
les lettres les lettres de condoléances
et les lettres
à l'occasion de son 95e anniversaire
accord douala comme honda c'est un peu
radine ne paye pas fait qu'elle aurait
dit à ses dames d'honneur que ça allait
la roubine et en temps il va falloir
répondre à tous ces gens là on veut donc
dire quelle date
c'est mal écrit pragmatique aller et
c'est quoi les cadeaux qu'elle est mal
an à part le foulard hermès dit on une
paire de gants en cuir à nouveau monter
à cheval
lmb les gants en cuir et elle adore les
cadres gabonais différents combos cadre
en argent par exemple en bronze
elle écartait qu'avec ce n'est pas une
merguez des photos fait rire mais c'est
vrai sans rigoler quoi alors il faut lui
offrir des quatre fêtes elle est très
simple elle est très simple ah ouais a
les traits campagne elizabeth
vous avez déjà rencontré où ils allaient
de bon dans le cadre de voyages
officiels paroisse titre prive de loin
quoi voilà vous avez rencontré qu'il en
angleterre ouais bah presque tout le
monde
turquie sur le prochain genre le prince
charmant mais sympa we are y arriver
sympa oui sympa aussi mais vous savez ce
qu'on leur demande pas d'être sa part
alors job sympa d'être sympa ah ouais
c'est de représenter le pays
c'est pour savoir c'est tout non mais
s'offre ses ex premier ministre anglais
et ce qui va la voir pour lui demander d
loris johnson il a envoyé une lettre est
alors apparemment oui
il a proposé que désormais les réunions
ne se fasse plus à buckingham
elles se feraient apparemment au château
de windsor mais se souvient que lorsque
victoria a perdu albert l'autre prince
consort en étant 1861 victoria n'a plus
quitté windsor on a d'ailleurs appelé la
veuve de windsor il semblerait qu'il va
se passer plus ou moins la même chose au
tour d'elisabeth de buckingham sera en
quelque sorte son secrétariat privé sont
durs j'adore mois ces histoires là ça
qui fait un bon j'en avais rien à carrer
et maintenant depuis que bertrand
carrière tu m'a fait aimer la monarchie
y voilà
il a abandonné certaines prérogatives
les voyages tout ça mais elle tient
comme elle est très fin politiquement
aller à fond elle tient elle-même a
rencontré le premier ministre pour leur
réunion hebdomadaire ou vrai quand on l
a jamais voulu délégué s'annonce est une
institution
ouais elle refuse d'ailleurs de le
prendre au téléphone une espèce les
lieux le voit oui mais alors ce qui est
triste et qu'elle ne va plus pouvoir
voyager parce que lorsque elisabeth de
voyage c'est quelque chose de fascinant
elle voyage avec son propre rythme elle
voyage avec son propre matelas elle
voyage avec son nouveau design de la
reine est fait avec la il donne est
vraiment loup officielle de la reine
elle voyage avec sa bouille est passé
avec lloris et tout est en quart à
madrid
ac après la paix a été tronquée quattro
[Applaudissements]